2020 completed and as it receives in the
rear view recitals to help you remember
this part too so i'm taking you through
all the news that occurs from july to
december
improbable horrors historical happening
is simply unstoppable
not comical so i'll chronicle all of
these obstacles quickly as possible july
we're already exhausted
looking back at all the damage done
disney plus releases us from board and
making available ham on
maybe he'd write his way out of this
misery but i'm not messing with that
just don't think it's that interesting
listening to history something's been
wrapped so many conspiracies spreading
online i'm having some trouble just
choosing one
hollywood liberals extracting adrenal
chrome what would we do with that
aussies in melbourne are not done for
months it's not a good day might
call that a knife this is a knife is it
a knife or is it okay celebrities
twitter accounts getting hurt
elon musk leaves that bitcoin scam block
hunter tychala is taken by cancer rest
in peace chadwick boseman ammonium
nitrate are rotten in lebanon cali the
fires are spreading
they're violent and cruel and ruining
lives almost as many as ellen
north korean leader in a coma called
that kim jong-il alan's arrested for
fortune and border wall funding conning
investors with skill cardi and megan
hook up for a banger excessive vulgarity
features
right-wing widow ben shapiro can only
say whereas p words
pretend it releases his cinema showing
that nolan's so dangerous when will we
learn
popcorn with
[Music]
young age you're 24. i might have gone
mixed up a word you expect that you'd
get comparing her to biggie smalls
schools are reopening students attending
because classes in person can't wait
a graphic math my ex where ladle are
using deciphering mortality rays
presidential debates commencing in haste
trump system back to the proud boys
shut up cause he died surprised from a
loud noise r.i.p to rbg
gop can't hide their enjoyment trump
voice is a choice for a pro-life judge
to proceed with a lifetime appointment
that's acb while aoc plays among us with
ilhan on twitch
and bad guys online try to body shame
billy saying irish they clear the fridge
van halen finally taps out in the bubble
the lakers succeed
president trump has covered being rushed
by chopper to walter reed his daughters
report
a sore throat and a slight thirsty
recovers while binge queen's gambit
which he loves
because white's first nasa discovers the
moon as some water is possible there
could be life
that's yet another place that we've
discovered is whatever men should hear
us
in kamala divided by plexiglas violet
out in salt lake the whole thing just
flies by except me i landed his old face
november 3rd election night trump
provided selection time
following by mail could be destined to
fail so we recommend you get in line
humans go red in the florida keys if we
trap results from the big screens we
won't even know the results for a week
midwest you pricked ease her records
have broken and so stone is hot even
though he exceeded his polls
and democrats got where republicans know
that they only got votes because they
stole
count every legal one quote those
dominion machines must be evil
tell us how you did it joe i guess i was
chosen by millions more people
playstation 5 is released but you better
be quick or willing to pay more
and if not at least you can play
cyberpunk at 10 fps on ps4
obama's been busy with writing and
finally releases his memoir
harry styles an address on the vote
cover there goes my no fap november
dolly partners me funding our vaccine
though there are some side effects
it will keep you working nine to five
but give you massive breasts
advice is ignore to not travel for
thanksgiving temps in a massive calamity
and we all have one place to fly back to
our childhood homes eat turkey and
murder our families expiring congress is
shameless
mcconnell decides that we can survive on
half we got given in april
government secrets are hot by the
russians security's so overwhelmed they
want to embarrass america
we already did it ourselves britain has
finally brexited boris declares no
crisis
preparing to trade with the world as you
export a mutated strain of the virus
vaccine is finally here prioritize
elderly people that's all of our leaders
so mike pence will survive and i won't
die
been a whole year without precedent all
of us living our lives in the precipice
every economy suffered from losses
unless you're investing in therapists
but look on the bright side next
pandemic will be ready
who could have produced this [ __ ] show
hindsight 20 20.
you